cerca de mi casa hay una florería y me
di cuenta de que la dueña acomoda las
flores de manera muy exacta siempre pone
10 flores por maceta y 10 macetas por
cada repisa
un día me animé a preguntarle por qué lo
hace de esa manera y me dijo que así es
mucho más fácil saber cuántas flores
tiene al tener una maceta llena quiere
decir que hay 10 flores y puede contar
las de 10 en 10 y si tiene una repisa
llena con 10 macetas ahí hay 100 flores
y puede contar las repisas de 100 en 100
y me sorprendió que al agrupar las
flores de ese modo es rapidísimo saber
cuántas flores hay ayer pasé por la
florería y había seis repisas llenas
otra repisa con cuatro macetas llenas y
una maceta con sólo ocho flores solo
asume 600 flores de las repisas llenas
más 40 de las macetas llenas y 8 por la
maceta incompleta y así supe que había
648 flores en total aquí notamos que
cada número representa algo el 8 son las
flores sueltas el 4 las macetas o grupos
de 10 flores y el 6 son las repisas con
100 flores cada una
en matemáticas esta organización de
números sirve para que podamos
separarlos sin afectar su valor al
número de la derecha se le llama unidad
porque su valor va de uno en uno al
siguiente se le llama decena porque va
de diez en diez y al tercero se le llama
centena porque va de cien en cien en el
caso de las flores que conté ayer
quedaría como seis centenas cuatro
decenas y ocho unidades
esto nos permite separar un número
grande en números redondeados que son
más fáciles de entender como por ejemplo
500 más 70 más 3 que sumando lo o al
acomodarlo por unidades decenas y
centenas forma el número 573 es muy
fácil verdad te invita a observar otros
números de este tipo que hayas escuchado
o que hayas visto en algún lugar intenta
con precios cuando acompañas alguien a
la tienda si observas que un juguete
cuesta 482 pesos
quiere decir que necesitas pagar 4
centenas 8 decenas y 2 unidades o 400
pesos más 80 pesos más 2 pesos esto es
de mucha ayuda porque así podemos
separar las cantidades para poder pagar
para los 400 pesos necesitamos 4
billetes de 100
para los 80 pesos podemos pagar con 8
monedas de 10
y para los dos pesos que restan lo
haríamos con dos monedas de un peso
espero que a partir de ahora separes
números en unidades decenas y centenas
para saber cómo apagar o simplemente
para sumar o restar de una manera más
fácil así que recuerda que si respetas
los lugares de cada número su valor
siempre será el mismo